[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
S
et la vie est
[Musique]
facile les poissons
sautent et le coton est
[Musique]
haut votre papa est
riche
et votre maman elle regarde
[Musique]
bien aussi chute petit bébé ne pleure
pas un de ces
[Musique]
qu
vous allez vous raser en
chantant vous allez étendre vos
[Musique]
AES et monter jusqu'au
ciel jusqu'à ce
[Musique]
matin rien ne peut t' arriver non
rien avec papa et maman à
côté je
t'aime c'est
dur quand tu m'as quitté je n'ai pas
très bien compris
pourquoi
j'étais trop orgueilleux
ou trop seul peut-être je ne sais plus
quel g
pourquoi c'est
[Musique]
l'été et tu m'as
quitté
with mmy and
Dady
stand i love youુ આ love
[Musique]
you બe બe સmer
time